what is this
we ran out of black rifled coffee
info didn't get changed processing thing
though uh we'll have some more
tomorrow yeah tomorrow
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
i was inspired to do a spit take because
wade did it so well but then i didn't
discuss it i saw you almost uh a quarter
of black gear is with us am i mirroring
to you properly right now
uh yeah okay because yesterday was a
technical disaster we all know because
we thought quarter black had the kovid
yeah turns out you didn't and
series of sketches boring of him as our
coveted correspondent
very disappointed come on so i do
apologize but we have so much to get to
today we have uh my half-assing larry
bill richmond is here obviously hello uh
everyone quarterback audio wait gerald a
but it's really important that my half
asian lawyer bill richmond is here
because we are going to
go through the 234 pages
of sworn affidavits just in the state of
michigan
right now and they say no evidence at
all a voter fraud
none at all or irregularities none at
all uh there are over 234 pages that you
can all read but they're handwritten and
they're not really labeled and i think
that someone should be hung from the
gallows before breakfast
uh for doing that but thank you to reg
the bandit and myself for spending an
hour and a half yesterday at 10 30
reading them just thank yourself
before we get to that this is something
just before we get into anything else
also we're passing the young turks today
which is kind of we'll do with a
celebration but this is something
in case you wondered if the left was
beyond parody
i just wanted to leave with this and
we'll go back to it with georgia voter
fraud
but um this is a new york times
columnist thomas friedman the
the lesser freedman the lesser
encouraging people
this was last night to move to georgia
just to vote for democrats
i hope everybody moves to georgia you
know in the next uh
a month or two uh registers to vote um
and votes
for these two democratic senators now
that may in a vacuum what does that
matter i actually
made that statement two days ago on this
show
as a joke only solely because i know
it's
highly illegal so here's the clip for me
two days ago i am this close to calling
every single louder with crowder viewer
and everyone here
to go rent out a timeshare or apartment
in georgia and voting the [ __ ] out of
those run-offs close to just
doing it but i know that we would be
caught
i made a joke about doing something
illegal i made a joke about the fact
that we would be caught doing something
illegal
two days later the new york times
columnist encourages people to do
something
illegal by the way half asian bill isn't
illegal that's totally illegal
i mean look there's a process by which
you can actually move to a statement
sure but the time frame and what their
specifically suggesting
is yeah no no it's a number not only is
there
evidence of voter irregularities and
fraud in the election
but if you could minority report this
right now you would arrest him
for committing voter fraud
months from now he just said and there
are more people who say the same thing
uh which all right hold on look at cnn
right now they're talking about
hospitalizations in copen so
um really quickly by the way we have a
lot to get to today do consider
following me on instagram uh because
it's
it's louder with crowder we do some uh
you know some lifestyle stuff
branding lifestyle branding ass modeling
and uh we will be taking your chats
later on at the end of this show
and uh do consider joining mug club
crowder election stream is still 30
dollars off
for college because the election is not
over
still bill you were saying this earlier
you were watching tv and
i don't know if you he always tries to
tone it down on air yeah it was
president-elect biden
and you had some words um i think it was
president
president elect yeah [ __ ] you biden yeah
i was like oh i was just sitting there
it's just
a legal briefing he's just using the
president-elect if you biden
oh okay
my question before we move on is which
battleground state do you think has
engaged in the shadiest
voting practices because now we're
looking at obviously of wisconsin you
have michigan you have pennsylvania
georgia you have arizona you have nevada
which one do you think is the most
egregious
uh we'll be going through state by state
next week so you can kind of have it as
a catalog
and a reference point because we've been
doing it as the info comes in but i do
understand it's tough sometimes
especially when they say well there's no
evidence
of any kind of voting irregularities and
you're like well there's so much but
where do i go
we got you covered good um and let me
know
comment right now take a second pause it
if you're watching this
in the archive and then come back to it
let me know if your mind changes after
you
see the michigan affidavits right before
we move on though
uh this is one of my favorite things
that happened this week a biden voter
being mobbed by the mob
trying to tell them that they shouldn't
mob them
[Applause]
be peaceful when i first saw that clip i
thought it was like
talking to them or preaching to them and
it was like a lectern or a stage right
but then you saw when i read the
language at the bottom i was like no no
this
because i was just watching instagram
and then i was like this is not that's
not there's no way that's what was
really being said and then i heard it
and i was like
oh i just i love pardon my language it
was just
it was bleeped but it's so funny people
need to watch that clip it's as though
you wrote a sketch
i voted for biden please be peaceful
[ __ ] you
they weren't going to burn your stuff
down right look i've got a sign i've got
a sign
still he's not he's very white
but i gotta say those protesters were
pretty spot on i mean
if if there's anyone as the the party of
white supremacy it's definitely
biden yeah yeah and his slave owning uh
first uh
pos uh candidate uh vp well i mean look
between the two of them one of them has
thrown more
more minorities in jail for victimless
crimes than the other
and uh it's her and one of them hasn't
has had their direct ancestors enslaved
more people than anyone in this room
that is also her wow no actually i
learned that footage was from a
democratic party meeting with the two
sides
nothing's changed and to be fair the the
pool is tainted but
anytime robert byrd shows up excuse the
average party yeah it's not a bell curve
it's a robert bird curve okay so let's
get into the michigan avid davids here
um i know this is boring for some people
i understand
uh but uh i want to make sure that you
understand
exactly what is in this document what
matters kind of some of these things are
tough to read
so first off this was introduced by um
quite the dish
kayleigh mac and any uh yesterday uh
here you go this is her announcement
we keep hearing the drum beat of where
is the evidence right here sean
234 pages of sworn affidavits these are
real people
real allegations signed with notaries
and then she was immediately cut off
[Laughter]
we'll have to talk about it later
chris wallace was then hosting hannity's
show right now
no no neil caputo this won't work with
my schedule for baby geniuses four
four tight sketches yes early production
so um
it's 234 235 pages of sworn affidavits
uh i want to go through what i think are
the most notable uh first off
uh half-assing bill can you explain to
people what a sworn affidavit is and why
it matters why it's not
just i think this election is bad right
it's a statement under oath i mean a lot
of people have had to fill them out
uh you know where you go to the bank or
you go to a notary
and that person is a witness they take
down your name they do the signature so
you have a record of making sure it's
a long process been around for a while
you know we're now doing some digital
signatures which is the electronic
version of that
but essentially saying like there has to
be a penalty if we're going to rely on
these words it's the central part of how
the legal system works is that you can
trust
that someone isn't going to just put
false information a statement and so
there are two different systems you have
the state and the federal at the federal
level
uh the penalties are wide-ranging
depending on the circumstance but you
could generally have about up to five
years
in federal prison and that's right so
yeah perjury applies to spread
affidavits just like being under oath in
court it does i mean when you are making
an under oath statement in writing in an
affidavit it is the equivalent of
sitting on the stand with a judge there
yeah making a statement again under oath
so in the state of michigan
which is where these affidavits are from
they actually have even more strict
penalties it can be up to 15 years and
it's a felony so
you would have to believe that these to
believe that these affidavits are false
you would have to believe that someone
was willing to give up not only more
than a decade
potentially of their own freedom but
also all the other things that go along
with being a felon right and the rights
that you lose
yeah and you don't you don't want to be
michigan's next ilhan omar
or sorry rashida tlaib the point is
their affidavits their hands on the
quran you're about to say something
there i was going to ask you so when
somebody makes a statement like that
doesn't doesn't somebody say are you
willing to sign an affidavit under oath
saying that this is true like isn't
there a process these people didn't just
go like i'm going to go find a notary
and make this statement right they were
appraised of kind of
the penalties potentially well they know
the penalties sure i don't know the
process let's not get too nerdy with the
process we'll go back to it but people
they know i'm just saying it didn't
happen by chance that's the whole no no
no
people didn't just run out and try to do
this like not knowing the consequences
there are many
there are many many hundreds totaling
well over a thousand affidavits
these are just from michigan by the way
i was looking this up someone can
probably fact-check me i might be off by
one or two
uh christine blasey ford i believe there
were four affidavits
and they were just affidavits of people
i think uh christine blasey ford told me
about a party
yeah that's it i mean i don't really
know what that is like i don't know how
you disprove that whereas these
affidavits are
uh very detailed as to what these people
saw taking place so let me give you one
here
um this is from page 17. the pdf is
available to everyone we'll have the
link up here
on page 17 someone said that there were
batches of ballots run through the
ballot machine
as many as five times this is a direct
quote
at approximately 4 50 a.m i witnessed a
man sprang a chemical on a ballot
machine he then placed 27
ballots into the machine and i noticed
tape on the top of the ballot where a
ballot number would normally be
throughout the night i witnessed him
insert these na these same 27 ballots
at least five times
legal or not half asian bill sounds
sketchy
[Laughter]
if any of this is incorrect if they can
prove is incorrect this person is in
trouble
yeah the person who made the statement
absolutely person is willing to
factual material statements that are
false
they will be likely found to have
committed perjury and yeah so here's the
other part is
so people will say oh well you know the
people who are signing it have no idea
they're just being told to sign this
stuff
but actually suborning perjury so going
out and procuring
perjury is perjury itself like it's also
within the perjury statute
as a crime here's the thing even if you
ask for someone to make a false
statement and they don't even make the
false statement
that's punishable right as a felony well
that's why i was getting into like where
these things came from
like they're the prime minister
everywhere the process of it is made
that has penalties that are involved
um and so like for that one just you
know being you know being very
straightforward
if you look at that same the question is
always going to be this is like what you
ask a question of
what is the way it's supposed to be
right and what is the way it's being
done
and what is the legal way to do it in
the way it's being done there are
reasons why you have to rerun ballots if
they're not read
but not running them five times not
re-running them 27 you know the same
with tape over the numbers
with tape over the number and it just so
happens to coincide with the
one one hour and a half nap that i took
yeah and the sudden jump which by the
way did really quickly they're saying
buy the leads trump by more than 5
million votes nationwide
well yeah if you read them five times
running the votes five times is that a
mundane detail michael
okay that's a good trick
love it here's another one uh this can
be found again on the pdf i want you all
to read it it'd probably take a couple
of hours
on page 25 page 116 page 122
page 138 page 158 page 185 we have over
six eyewitnesses testifying that ballots
not in the voter database
were just entered using a fake birth
date of one
one nineteen hundred oh wow wow why
would it's just a terrible date
six separate witnesses again check up
all those pages uh
this is and this is also interestingly
enough this is an excuse that's often
used when we talked about dead voters
going well we just uh just sometimes
they're just entering
the 1900 as a birthday that's also not a
legitimate vote
if it doesn't match the birth date of
the person in question
you're not supposed to correct it on
your own because there's one person here
who said that their son voted who's dead
twice now all of the local news said
that that had been
disproven but they didn't actually
provide sources to it being this proven
what i had read was they said well
sometimes if they're
part of a new township that's created
they'll just give him like a birthday
like 1900. that's also an illegal vote
uh fact he actually only voted once
right yeah that was their fact
we have a new town and so here's the
thing
it's like there were some examples where
um you know the
the birth date was illegible they put a
a
like a placeholder birthday in there of
1900 and then they go back and they
follow those up
and so even if i mean this is the entire
problem i have with anyone going
no there's no fraud at all there's no
irregularities we shouldn't look at any
of this just
crown biden and move on right is there
are legitimate
irregularities that the system is
already set to review
right so we're not saying hey do an
extraordinary review don't do anything
that's abnormal
canvas the districts look at the votes
check the ballots
check the things that are irregular and
and let the chips fall
by the way that's important you just
said canvas districts this is something
i want everyone to know
it's in georgia for example and keep in
mind too the georgia secretary of state
this isn't anyone involved even if
they're a republican they don't want to
say
yeah i was involved in the most
incompetent voting process
even if it's not scandal so they're not
necessarily going to be looking as
aggressively as possible regardless of
political affiliation because it
reflects badly on them as well if they
didn't catch it
but this is something that was
overlooked and i would say even on our
show we didn't have enough time
in georgia people just think oh just a
recount explain to people
what the canvassing is the recount how
that's different a manual recount and
why it could
change things dramatically and catch
fraud because it's not just going all
right recounting and there might be
differences if you vote
well it's looking at in every state the
ballots are a little different they have
different requirements for example in
wisconsin you know there's the witness
and the address
requirements right they're made out of
cheese sometimes they have a little bite
if it's swiss cheese you may miss a
candidate
but when brett favre shows you his penis
oh
i think he lives in a different state
atlanta really yeah he abandoned them
quickly
sorry go ahead so stephen no sports
every difference
i love when stephen mentioned sports
it's like i know i'm gonna get
gobbledygook yeah it's when
except except for a [ __ ] saying
gobbledygook
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so when you go to different the
different states
before they can certify they have to do
canvassing and people are going
i can't believe they're asking for this
canvassing i don't know we've only been
doing canvassing our entire
nation like entire history of certified
votes
again not every state has it every state
does a little bit differently
all we're saying is do the process you
normally do and in an
election where it's not that close no
one pays attention
but just because you didn't know
canvassing happens and that canvassing
is required and remote certification is
happening and reviewing
the irregularities and checking to make
sure they're right doesn't mean that
that hasn't
already been i think this comes down to
if people believe that this is
legitimate or not for example just
because you didn't know that canvassing
happens
just because you didn't know for example
like i think that vote should count but
he wasn't born in 1900
why well so well that's illegal i didn't
know that
it doesn't matter that's not a defense i
don't care what detroit free press told
you
if you were born in 1967 and uh it says
1900 and it doesn't match your
voter registry that is no that is not a
legitimate vote because we cannot know
what is accurate or not
yeah absolutely and i think we've just
gotten so used to the media calling an
election and we just trust okay those
are the results and we had no idea this
entire process went on until around
december 14th i think when they actually
say
yep votes certified in each one of the
states right and we just thought it
happened the night of the election right
and
and cnn went out of their way to make
sure that we knew that that wasn't the
process
right up until their guy was the
beneficiary and then they said nothing
to see here move along
this is extraordinary well it's more
than fierce than that they weren't
trying to let us know that that wasn't
the process they were trying to let us
know that actually this time
we wouldn't even know the winner yeah
period yeah we wouldn't
because usually the process is used but
media will call it and they work with
local officials and they go okay we have
a general
we think we have an accurate count right
but they were saying don't believe any
of it
right if trump wins and they had to keep
saying it
up until 4 25.
and you know how you know how here's the
thing when they say well we knew that
biden was going to pull ahead
do you know how you know that's not true
chank wieger who we will not mention
after this stream
was losing his mind oh yeah up until
midnight
he dated everybody democrats did not see
it as a as a surmountable lead at that
point
they were just as surprised if they were
saying hey listen keep calm all as well
winning florida by double digits by
twice the margin of last time i think
last time 1.5 was three point something
i don't know the
total tally they would have said that
hey listen it's gonna change when the
mail in ballots comes no they
all you could see it was like it was
like a death march
and then said what what hold on a second
at 4 51 in the morning like how did this
change
it's like i don't know shouldn't you ask
i don't ask questions
when the banker favors me i don't say
anything where's jesse ventura when you
need him all he does is ask questions
never provides answers not at all no
what happened with that voting machine
i don't know what do you think happened
i'm just asking the questions
always the interviewer never the
interviewee was the w bush family
sitting down there
behind the tallying machine with the
soddy prince
and an acme plunger blowing up tower
seven is that what you're suggesting i'm
just asking
questions regarding the facts with my
creepy riffraff
so one thing i would say is very
interesting because i've talked to a lot
of people i think i've mentioned this
before
before the election you know there's not
a lot of court going on these days so
i'm like not getting my fix of
adversarial
conversations right normally do you call
me up at two in the morning just to
argue yeah exactly
i'm like no you should not be wearing
spandex this is not the time of year
it's probably right um
and so i would go talk to a bunch of
folks i'm still doing that today
and a lot of folks on the on the left
like folks who are just openly they
supported by they go
we need to count the votes they're like
just let the pro
like i don't want to have to answer to
someone and say oh we just won because
we shuffled it under the bed yeah
but that is not what you're hearing in
like on cnn
they're like i'm looking around and
seeing these headlines but
none less than half of america believed
biden one people don't understand that
exactly there have been several polls
that have come out to that effect and
people like just count and i go
i go exactly i go you that's the kind of
stuff you need to be telling other
people they're like
but everyone around me is saying can we
this is america why
aren't we following the law like yeah
why are we stopping following the law
let's just count the votes this is the
thing they did well hey listen you can't
molotov cocktail
of five below well i didn't know that
where is that well still we're still
gonna have to arrest you
i don't think so no we're gonna arrest
you that vote is not legitimate
i didn't know it doesn't matter yeah
that does not matter i had a friend who
got arrested because
or or he was he was detained because he
accidentally
caught a species of fish in lake
michigan that you were not allowed to
fish huh
and he legitimately could claim
ignorance because everyone
and he was a could hockey player like ah
you can't do that we have to bring you
in he's like
what is this this that's illegal he goes
but what is it
they said does it really matter we'll
just show you it's illegal said all
right and he took his licks
all right here's another one uh this is
from page
37 uh regarding mail in voting
poll watchers observed mail-in ballots
being logged even when they had no
signature
or weren't a registered voter again you
can find this in the pdf on page
37. we have seen this happening uh acro
or many sworn affidavits across the
country again all of this is just
michigan there are also numbers coming
in that there are disproportional
number of ballots that just had biden
harris and i can't verify this but
it hasn't really largely been disputed
whereas just biden harris
and not the rest of the ticket nothing
else which is very very weird well and
one of the this is the signature thing
pisses me off more than just about
anything else because that was what they
assured us would be the backstop they
said no no no
mail and ballots are fine because we can
check the signatures right and that will
be fun and just to just to go well yeah
i don't know you put an x over yeah why
over there it's fine they did fix it
because we've talked about this long
before this show
about how many votes could be
compromised because a lot of ballots
either didn't have signatures
or the signatures didn't match but now
they just said good enough
so it's not the same hold on that
voter's name is paul and it says
john he wrote john hancock he was
playing ironic no he wasn't being ironic
that's not the right signature and now
also you have ballots accepted
mail-in ballots at 30 times the rate of
any other election
unbelievable because any signature is
good enough think about that for a
second all of these things and then
something that is
statistically observable no one can
dispute this whatsoever
mail-in ballots in the year the first
time they were unrequested
accepted at 30 times the rate
rejection rate was one percent what it
used to be now it's like 0.03 something
percent
those add up over 100 000 votes couple
million votes
those aren't just those aren't that's
not a rounding error that's winning a
state
yeah exactly and that's just one factor
right go to postmarks and everything
else and you start to add these things
up and it becomes a huge number of votes
turned
so but gerald if only there was a way
for us to double check into
yeah sure that the thing network i think
the winner's already been declared bill
i apologize we have to move on
if only our government already put a
process
into place to double check these votes
and give wait we already have one
right but i didn't know that oh oh
i guess um just give joe biden the
trophy what you think the president gets
a trophy
well a plaque then fine he gets a plaque
he doesn't get anything
he becomes leader of the free world well
i didn't know that
well i'm going to tell you guys i think
you're making a make it a big mistake
even referring
you know in any way to think that this
is going to be a biden presidency
um you know this is definitely kabla all
day
every day i sent her a cookie bouquet
just to hedge my bets okay
right justin i bet sometimes i go to a
methodist church and not just a baptist
church just to hedge my best friend
what you do if you want uh if you want
to send joe biden a gift send him a gift
that you really want for yourself but
you can do without for about
nine months to a year and a half and put
a return on yours
look i got you a new nintendo switch huh
yeah
yeah oh i kept keep the gift receipt and
uh
should something happen you see there's
a contr contractor that says it
just returns back to its right send it
back huh
what you're leader of the free world
well i didn't know that
so here's another one duplications this
is on page 107. if we go
for on before this why is morticia adams
on cnn right now no that's dick durbin
the other day she was doing she was
doing the little uh the little
shoulder pads like orphan and now she
just how funny would it be if that guy
just reached into her little box and
she's like
got a mia what is this crime i'm telling
you
are you starting are you saying it's
unprofessional yeah yeah
yeah i am and i know this is one thing
women act as though they have
it harder in the workplace because oh
men wear uniform
could you imagine if you walked in today
wearing ruffles
wearing a pirate ruffle shirt you're
getting beaten up or just a
lace negligee what are you doing that's
unprofessional stephen the number of
times before the show started and i've
had to tell gerald to take
to take the ruffles off that's true i'm
i'm really protecting you here i think
it'll work
it works come on i'm not saying you
didn't look good at it i'm saying it's
unprofessional he's tall
so the lines he can do the horizontal
lines i know by the way uh
half asian build doesn't matter how many
vertical lines you try and put on your
suit
we can tell i was going to say i want
you to notice that cnn always has the
popular
vote up the irrelevant statistic is
always there
they don't show you that it's an 11 000
vote difference in arizona they don't
show you that it's
under 20 000 in a couple of other states
they just show you oh the popular vote
it's almost 6 million now of course you
will see no evidence of voter fraud no
evidence of voter irregularities none
whatsoever
there's a lot there's a lot now as to
whether there's enough to flip all of
these states
but anyone who says there is no evidence
they're lying to you discount them
immediately
just like if someone says i guarantee
you donald trump won discount them
immediately right that is not
information that is valuable because
this person does not know we do not know
exactly what is trade what has happened
with this election we do
know that there are illegitimate votes
we do know that there are irregularities
and in some cases fraud to the level of
which that we don't know
this is from page 107 a poll watcher saw
poll workers duplicating ballots
to incorrect precincts uh in order to
run through
two ballots for one person and uh they
said that they observed this repeatedly
about 20 to 30 times
so of all the different allegations this
is one of the ones that i think is
is a very much like there's no r there's
no innocent explanation for that
right if they saw what they saw which
and i realized they've signed and said
that this is what they saw
um but look having worked in law you see
people who everyone will see the same
scene and remember things a little bit
differently
or there's some explanation but that's
one of the ones where it's really hard
to think of
how could there be an explanation you
saw the ballot it had a precinct you saw
another ballot it had the same person
with the same votes but with the
different precinct
and then they both get run through right
right there's no there's no legitimate
explanation for that
and it's one of the examples that we
have to look to get to the bottom of and
here's one other point
let's say that the presidential election
doesn't change let's say that the
swing states the battleground states
they are what they are and trump doesn't
end up winning
there's still a lot of other ballots
that matter we're coming into a 2021
redistricting cycle
right the state legislatures are the
ones that determine that so knowing that
the val
the balance for those less less popular
uh of candidates or less popular uh
races
is really really important especially
when you've already had
people who conceded and then they were
like oh by the way he's like oh you're
bullshitting
ah think about this for a second how
would you not want to investigate an
election
where you had a six thousand vote slip
yeah just to flip and they go well
we caught it so the system works well
hold on a second you caught it in one
district and you're claiming it works i
would prefer that it didn't happen
at all seems it's an oversight that six
thousand votes were miscounted for the
wrong guy
entirely and we also have another in
michigan
a republican who conceded and then they
found out actually won by a thousand
votes
which in that district is a lot yeah
that's a significant margin this
happened
just just those two examples wouldn't
that warrant an investigation of
every vote in the state of michigan six
thousand votes that's consequently a
national election
and a local guy lost until he won i
don't know
you know what and if it's a glitch i
mean if someone here if someone here
came forward with proof
that gerald had groped them once and i
was like well how do you know and i see
videographic evidence of his hand
sliding up a thigh and then
another one is just a video graphic
evidence of him later on
servicing himself in the bathroom i'd be
like you know what now i think that we
need to look into this and i go through
the ring security footage because i
found two examples that's enough
why am i the exact for example
[Laughter]
if tubin did it twice yeah wouldn't it
be worth a probe
not the kind of probe would like but a
probe into how many times has two been
done this it happened two times it
affected the
the outcome of elections in michigan
that's not
that's not no evidence no that happened
yeah and there's some
yeah i don't understand where they get
the no evidence claim they cannot like
the evidence they cannot like what
they're seeing and think maybe it's not
going to change
right but there is evidence that stuff
happens irrefutable evidence yeah um
by the way hit the notification bell
speaking of irrefutable evidence because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot on
youtube and the notification bell goes
straight to your mobile app and uh tells
you uh or your phone your mobile app i
don't know
i am tired i'm not taking a break since
election nor weekends
um and uh we do good morning michael of
course weekdays at 10
a.m eastern here's another one this is
from page 172
of the pdf that is publicly available
right good thing
the good thing about the green new deal
is everyone could read it because it was
five pages it was written by
a functionally [ __ ] person um this
is a little bit tough because most
people don't want to comb through 235
pages
before you can read right and when you
always hear the left they go
we're the party of nuance you're you you
were going to take over the economy with
five
pages and it was double spaced yeah it
was double spaced
and this is 234 and you don't have any
interest
it'll be the party of nuance come on yes
uh this is page 172
um a poll watcher examined a box of
ballots and found
60 percent or more had the same
signature
that's totally different again we need
to investigate this but this is a sworn
affidavit
right that comes in with supervision
will find exactly that's why they don't
want it and this is a question that i
did have for you uh
half vision letter bill um how many of
these things if you do a hand count can
be found versus not so for example this
is one you can find if they all the same
signatures
but if uh some of these uh you know
secretive secret ballots
have been destroyed like there are some
things that could be covered up
afterward
right right so one of the hardest ones
are ballots that don't actually make it
into the system
so if they never got received and that's
uh you know if they're ballot boxes or
drop-offs and they just don't get
collected or they get dumped or they get
sorted
before they're taken in it's really hard
because you don't have anything in the
counting right the counting presumes
that you already have but there's not
really anything you can do about that at
this stage what about back dating like
the ones that have been backdated
can you find those okay in some states
they keep a record of when it was
actually received and it went through a
process where it was stamped though as
we saw
there have been questions about where
they stand appropriately on that day or
not sometimes
they're dated in the ballot itself so
for example you know that it was sent
the day before the election and then
somehow it got in and had a date
from the day two days before the
election right you know you've got a
problem i would actually say that
especially when they just they put the
date into 1900
yeah right then you're like the wrong
fraud
bad fraud pete i knew i should have
found you for our fraud campaign
one of the one of the actual problems
with the multiple signatures that are
the same though
is you can only know that if someone
notices it if you have a thousand people
counting
and you have the same thousand signature
one for each person yeah
you may not reach and it's really hard
to notice if the entire voting precinct
is an arena covered in bristol boards
right yeah or you're like 60 feet away
you know from that that's like there's
some of this too you just have to put
two and two together
right they were planning putting up
wallpaper on
glass yeah bill when have you ever seen
that outside of a horror movie
and that's only because people are
acting in the exact opposite way that
someone would react in their life
who puts wallpaper on glass especially
democrats
observing what's going on behind that
glass but also the guidance that they
were given bill the guidance
that says even if the signature doesn't
match or even if it doesn't have a
signature even if the postmark isn't
clear
even if it is after the deadline go
ahead and accept that go ahead and say
that that is a legitimate valid can't we
go back and find that that's illegal
conduct to say
guys go ahead and do it even though
that's against our state laws right i
think that's what they're alleging
happened in pennsylvania
and in some of these districts folks
were giving the wrong instructions and
and
look it's not that it doesn't happen in
every election the question is is it
happening
in the key precincts in the key
districts right having a material effect
on the outcome of the election
and when i say the election i mean the
entirety of the election we're not just
the presidential elections yeah right
and and so one of the but one thing that
just i don't want you to let that one
thing to be clear
it really only takes one or two
precincts per state
to change it so people think it has to
be widespread across the state no wayne
county is
enough in pennsylvania especially when
you have some states that are 20 000
votes or wisconsin
it can be one or two precincts so we
need to be clear about that
we're not just talking about every
individual's home these
these ballots are collected in basically
what are giant uh ballot farms
effectively right and then if it's
covered up in bristol board and they
don't let anyone in then
okay well now you know that you're
screwed well think about a state like
arizona if you have maricopa county that
far exceeds
almost every other county in terms of
numbers yeah so you could make it look
like very little of a problem by framing
it like
well one of 34 counties had
right two percent error rate in the
counting of ballots
one candidate versus another or two
percent of them didn't actually
get in or two percent of them had
irregularities that we ignored
despite and we counted them but then you
go and you're like okay well but how
many is that two percent and how much is
that two percent against the rest of the
oh oh it actually is 11 right because
there are a number of people so
you know that you have to look at the
objective numbers and also
uh the percentage we'll just give you an
idea when people say wow how can the
county affect it uh
wayne county we talk about detroit that
affects the crime rate of the entire
state
[Laughter]
like murder in michigan is basically
detroit
it's detroit and every now and then
there's a little bit of a scuffle at the
drive-in in muskegon
outside of that that's what it is
people don't realize this when when bill
clinton tried to claim credit for tough
on crime right in the in
the 90s it was rudy giuliani in new york
that affected the entire national crime
level violent crime level
so you need to understand how much a
state can be affected by just
one county all of michigan you if you
talk with michiganders right people who
don't actually live in detroit they're
like if we could just annex that [ __ ]
and send it to canada we would be better
off
because they know how much influence it
has and how corrupt it is for crying out
loud
this is how people talk about chicago
corruption i don't know that we've had a
mayor
i think probably two out of three mayors
in detroit have been investigated if not
arrested
that guy kwame who was mayor in detroit
yeah his his wife may or may not have
killed prostitutes who he had in the
mayor's mansion
and he tried to flee they caught him at
the dallas airport remember
yeah they were like hey not only is he
criminal he's stupid
like what do you think they don't need
to extradite you when you land
in dallas bad plan get an international
flight you [ __ ]
so gerald to your point about the
instructions yeah um you know there have
always been
issues where you know you worked in one
state and then you move to another state
and then you're in the next election
right helping to work and the
instructions are different or the
instructions have changed because of the
rules or there were a lot many
you know a lot of last-minute legal
rulings that were had and you've got to
communicate that to lots of people who
the last time they did this was the last
cycle two years ago and the instructions
were a little bit different right so
when you have legitimate claims of
questions about instructions being given
correctly
or the process not being done according
to the instructions that were given
you have to be able to answer those
right it's it's it's again
part of the process we already have in
place well in pennsylvania the supreme
court had to come a third time
to tell them no evidence now okay let's
be peaceful
now we are going to go back in just 30
seconds with actually potential new
voter fraud as expressed by the new york
times and
the yang gang hey now you know why i
hate you guys
uh sorry i know but you know he's not
emblematic of all you guys no
ah but right now really quickly a word
from our sponsor expressvpn
[Music]
i think everybody's gone
yeah it looks like everyone's gone in
the back too i'll uh i'll get the snacks
and stuff do you want to fire up the
projector
have you seen this one yet uh yeah i've
seen it like eight times but
find something new each viewing every
snap it's time for a baking snap
protect your business with expressvpn
and by the way this is we are going to
be talking about passing tyt
right it's the hashtag crowder passes
tyt
crowder passes just if it gets trending
it just be a nice little cherry on top
but if you go to expressvpn.com crowder
you get i want to make sure i get this
right you get uh three months free and
extra three months free
we've used expressvpn we use it when
sort of actually figuring out some of
the algorithms with social media
but here's also where a vpn is valuable
because
all of your data is private right and
you can't be trashed uh trust you can't
pass it i was trying to say traced and
tracked
no you didn't do either one i just buy i
just pulled a biden
just so you know the thing is my left
side drooping
can i become ceo of pfizer now oh i'm
sorry sir i'm doing my best
um i when i use expressvpn it doesn't
matter what i watch
it still auto-suggests seth meyers
really because we've talked about this i
don't know why
it doesn't matter if i'm watching
anthony kumia if you're listening to a
bill bird podcast or nick depaolo
it could be ben shapiro it always
suggests
seth meyers who is demanding seth
meyer you don't want to know what seth
meyers did at youtube headquarters
you we will make gerald do those things
no no no no
no you know and here's the other part
right a lot of folks are like hey wait a
minute we've got big tech we got big
data they're out there they're taking
all this information they're selling it
and they're making these online profiles
like one of the best ways to just
carve back a little bit of that is using
expressvpn you don't even have to use it
when you're doing
secret stuff or whatever you know stuff
that has to be you know whether trade
secrets or work or confidential
you can just you use it during your
everyday browsing and other things like
that
whether fetish or otherwise yes you know
all about that asians i don't know why
it is that
men love well your dad is white and you
were just telling me today that your dad
beats you at ping pong
he's so really whoa now was your dad
only interested in asian women though
was that like his thing because
i feel like a lot of guys who i know
like they don't know
who did he do all the commercial guys
well i wasn't alive then
you never asked him no no no like my dad
always
liked blondes and so my mom made sense
you know i didn't know like but the guys
who have
i know a guy who was married and he was
like i i only date asians and i actually
this was his response i said like oh and
i think asian women obviously are
beautiful of the hair and institution
exotic especially too
man i love those ladies with hair
straight black hair but he actually made
this reaction i said what about like
what are you ever like if there's like a
nice white woman he went ugh
oh wow so yeah not i don't i don't know
i mean i know that i
before marrying my wife who's mexican i
had never dated any minority at all
right okay you know a period of dare but
that was just because i'm insane losing
there's like not that many you know what
are you talking
about are you kidding me at least where
i was well he didn't make the drive to
ferguson oh god there's a there's a
great old nor mcdonald joke it's uh
that ping pong is the only sport named
after its inventor
wow but but my dad is very good at ping
pong yeah my chinese grandmother so on
my mother's side
was better than him and would beat him
regularly yeah so i think really the
moral of the story is i'm
terrible at ping pong no you're actually
pretty good you're pretty good and
you're great i would imagine your
chinese grandmother does while chain
smoking cigarettes and then swallowing
them backwards because it's just
holding oh wow they smoke
cnn before we go to the next version of
election fraud we'll know the final
arizona tally soon
trump touts arizona vote count while
dismissing other results
this is one of those things they just go
without context isn't that hypocritical
oh honestly let me ask you did we
already verify
6 000 votes accidentally went to the
other guy in arizona yeah
was there an actual local seat that
flipped after a republican conceded in
arizona no this happened in michigan
yeah that doesn't mean that nothing
wrong has happened with arizona because
of course there were military ballots
that came in late there's some
just ballots that didn't come in on time
at all but it's not just hypocritical
because you go oh you know what maybe
that
state did it right and that state didn't
and yeah
it's still he's also not contesting the
results in new york
right yeah to be clear exactly or
florida or california
he's not only contesting states where he
lost we're only talking about states
where there's verified
evidence of nefarious activity which
again you say does not exist
so someone watching this not
understanding the context goes well it's
hypocritical
no no no no he's not contesting all
states just the ones where we have
verifiable proof
of some [ __ ] now again to minority
report this
the left is now being open about
committing
voter i don't know voter fraud it
wouldn't be
an irregularity because it's before like
an irregularity doesn't happen before
hand you don't plan an irregularity is
right you're saying yeah
and if you think it might happen you get
some benefit
whatever the fiber thing is what is it
fiber what's me what's the fiber thing
beneful i see commercial poop joke are
you are you recycling ted cruz's poop
joke no i'm not recycling ted cruz
what's what's the fiber thing that you
drink the orange drink cafe
[Laughter]
so in georgia we are going to have
runoff elections and i know some people
say hey what's that well you don't
really need it it just means it's gonna
be another election okay for people who
don't necessarily pay attention
um for which party controls the senate
now i actually think this is more
important because when people talk about
you know kamala harris with a tiebreaker
senate people don't realize that vp is a
tie-breaking vote uh
but uh keep in mind that when we're
talking about the number of republicans
in the senate it still is including mitt
romney
so minus one yeah can't trust that guy
party affiliation sandy vagina
it's going to be a tough one it's a
growing movement yeah but hey
but hey you know from every sandy vagina
comes a pearl
[Laughter]
that makes sense have you ever seen an
oyster i get clam yeah um
so the new york times columnist thomas
friedman yeah we showed you this earlier
today but it gets worse i
want to revisit this he encouraged
people to move to georgia to vote
in the runoffs here you go i hope
everybody moves to georgia
you know in the next uh a month or two
uh registers to vote um
uh and votes uh for these two democratic
senators
that guy looks like dennis farina bang
someone who sells meatball sandwiches
so that and then i want to go through
andrew yang sorry but andrew yang
tweeted a similar strategy let's call it
uh he said everyone who campaigned for
joe should get ready to head to georgia
i'll go there isn't much time bro the
earliest date for absentee ballots to be
mailed
for the runoff is november 18th the
registration deadline is december 7th
the in-person voting i mean he's laying
out a blueprint
bro it seems to me that uh they are
suggesting
what i believe to be correct me if i'm
wrong possibly
felony voter fraud so the
italian meatball sub sandwich guy yeah
so his thing
seems much more closer to what would be
voter fraud so encourage
and it's not just fraud to go and do it
but to encourage someone
or purchase their vote which has been
suggested that oh you could pay
people to go down and yeah chelsea
handler with 50 cent by offering him
sexual favors to vote for biden yeah i
think that's a problem
someone prosecute that broad i don't
care how many books she writes about
vodka you're a [ __ ] we get it no no no
i belong in prisoners i believe in
prisoner's rights we would not want to
put her with them yeah that would be
terrible but it would put a smile put a
um but but i will say and this is
something that's very important is the
fight isn't over
with regards to this runoff so when
andrew yang is saying hey he's going to
go there and help and they're going to
increase the number of people that are
out there doing not
ballot counting or ballot canvassing but
door-to-door
vote canvassing to make sure that people
are voting for the election
and that they're going to send
additional money and they're going to
have all these ballots this is the time
when uh if people let off the gas in
this particular election
you know it may have even more dire
consequences than losing the white house
is to also lose the senate so you don't
think that andrew yang was saying try
and set up a
residency his stuff does not seem to be
set up residency well i guess it's
because the other guy
yeah yeah well by the way just because i
know it's different from states of state
a spokesperson for the georgia secretary
of state's office we're back to there uh
they received voter registrations
they did cite a state law uh that is a
felony to vote in georgia elections if
you are not a legal resident
or if you're just residing in the state
briefly with the intention to vote and
then move away
i was joking when i said that two days
ago
because i knew it was highly illegal i
thought it was so
obviously illegal like you know when i
joke about like killing a hobo throwing
them in the ozarks
you know i'm not gonna do it wait that
was a joke it was a joke when i said
it no you did it right but the point is
i was so absurd i took it to the extreme
like let's all move and get to
apartments uh condos in georgia i even
told we all had a big laugh about it in
the control room i said i'll buy you all
time shares everyone said
stephen you're incorrigible and then we
saw the guy from the new york times talk
and it wasn't funny anymore oh he
thought it was a good idea
i heard it from stephen crowder we
should be advised
dennis fiorina's bastard this is just
amazing to me that they are saying so
let's just move to georgia to vote
like cramp and then they want to talk
about how oh we need to do away with the
electoral college why because it should
just be based on the popular vote that's
what's best representative of americans
you think that most representative of
georgians is a bunch of the yang gang
moving into a timeshare sleeping on bean
bags so they can throw their vote and
then go on their merry way
no you think that represents the average
american
they don't care about representation
they don't care about the systems of law
in this country
they care about simply doing whatever is
necessary to win an election
whether legal that's weird whether legal
or not this is illegal
this is illegal can someone investigate
the new york times guy
friedman can someone can someone call
him in for questioning if they're going
to call james o'keefe in for questioning
for
running his biggest crime is running a
camera while someone else says hey i'm
about to commit a federal crime and then
they interrogate
james o'keefe but now you have a new
york times writer
encouraging a crime can someone put the
heat lamp into his face
right there's got to be a tweet that he
followed this up with too right he's got
a
written about it as well it's like
you've got evidence the only acceptable
follow-up tweet to change the scenario
is hahaha just joshing
or you should arrest him yeah exactly no
he probably doubled down in the tweet is
what i'm saying
so it's not just that i mean even the
wall street journal was publishing
articles about how you could go and get
established there and the georgia
government has maintained like look you
there is process for which you would
have to establish residency
right even if you do end up establishing
residency but your entire point was just
to come in
establish residency vote and leave
that's still legal illegal yeah so
it's not only i mean if you want to come
in and work on a campaign you can do
that and in fact that's i think what
andrew yang is trying to do
uh versus uh bushy mcmeat balls was
i think go down there do your vote and
then move away
right no problem or just go down there
don't even establish true residency
because for example you could like get a
georgia driver's license so you have to
like give up your driver's license from
another state get it there
and go through those steps there are a
couple different ways to establish
residency in georgia but you can't just
go in
vote and roll out i just wish that i i
had the life of a complete lack of
accountability because i remember
we were moving from michigan to texas i
remember talking with my accountant
and asking about voting absentee and i
said hey we're talking about how we pay
taxes right you said well actually what
you really would have to prove is that
you are in this state for more than six
months out of the year so it relates to
taxes and specifically the release of
voting right
none of these questions matter to these
folks not at all
georgia driver's license is good enough
for me do you think they ever have a
conversation do you think they have any
of the legal counsel just think of how
many conversations we have had where you
go
uh stephen i think it might be this is
an actual conversation half vision bill
goes i think it might be illegal for you
to drink
half a bottle of epicock and go into the
dmv
i remember though yeah that seems like a
democrat no one would care
it was somewhere between 11 and 97
reasons why that was not a good idea
yeah half of which were legal
this was an actual thing that we did not
do because remember they were doing the
sickening when donald trump at his
hotels
trump care makes me sick in all the
trump hotels
so we wanted to say that government
bureaucracy makes me sick right so i was
gonna drink epic [ __ ]
like but like 20 of us and go into the
dmv and just be vomiting
and it turns out that that could
technically be misconstrued as vandalism
of federal property
misconstrued of course whatever
advocated against but the point is
peaceful protest i made the right
decision yeah
my parents told me to make good choices
and i do
most of the time yeah sometimes but if
not for him i would have consumed epica
the really hard part was trying to find
epicock apparently you can't get that
anymore because they say it doesn't work
yeah
they say that it doesn't actually work
to use epicox and vomit like if it was
used to stop
uh you know like poisoning poison oh
okay apparently it doesn't work
well but i had a guy so i will say it
was very difficult
but that was not what stopped us it was
the
it was this man right the kraken rebound
says you're looking at your phone or
you're just that dis
no i was trying to see if there were any
other sources that were also encouraging
and there are a ton of people who are
saying just move to georgia
of course if you want to move to georgia
and stay there fine
yeah that's on you hey you know it's
almost like cnn could investigate it
because they're
in georgia right yeah they think
like when yesterda when yesterday i
think was yesterday the secretary of
state was talking
and uh they didn't show it it was hap it
was just it was happening on their
street
yeah i mean here's a look out of the
window i mean they say what the hell is
going on out there
close the blinds there's also a level of
line where things are not voter fraud or
they're not illegal but they're just
clearly intended to game the system yeah
and thus immoral
right and so you know for for i feel
like we've only heard about this for
every day of the last four years about
one party being
the moral party and the other one not
and uh
and and now to say well we're just gonna
go ahead get a bunch of people
registered
have them all come here say that they're
staying and then influence the election
and essentially game the system to
take the senate okay maybe you didn't
maybe you didn't do something illegal if
you do
jump through all the hoops but you
definitely did something wrong well
except the secretary of state is illegal
in georgia yeah some of that is illegal
what part's not illegal if you move
there
and you are actually going to stay and
you get registered in time and you turn
in the ballot
become a falcon fan you could vote but
if you just like leave in january
you've got a problem i mean part of this
probably stay in georgia no but yeah
none of these people they're all going
to move back to williamsburg or brooklyn
or
i'm not a hobo i mean i don't want to
insult i don't want to insult a large
portion of our viewership georgia's a
horrible place
no georgia's nice i prefer the georgia
country wow they
just can't even hold their own against
the russians i would rather be in that
georgia
than you're georgia so georgia get your
[ __ ] together hey georgia
we love you he does we just don't like
your cnn
yeah we don't like that but we do find
it funny when the cnn gets
burned down by like no no yeah and then
cnn
they were reporting on like please stop
and then they found out that the reason
and
marauders were breaking down the
buildings because there was a police
precinct in that same building right
yeah i just got them they're in the
second floor oh yeah they don't even
care about cnn
was hiding under his desk like it was a
50s bomb drill
yeah exactly fire doesn't go up a
building does it so we're safe on the
fifth floor
i have no idea all right listen this is
something else we have to get to it's a
long time coming
but uh this uh right now today or
tomorrow we will have officially
surpassed uh the young turks on the
youtube as the number one independent
news channel
oh my god oh there it is i can't drink
from my woo
so here's the deal it's a little
i thought this was gonna be bigger than
it was yeah you're talking about the
streamers
no no no the whole thing passing the
young turks again you can post uh
crowder passes tyt but let me give you a
story of the saga and why it matters
there were like months that i just
dreamed about this yeah as a kid
because you have to understand i was a
kid i was 19 years old this was back in
2008 2009 where i was doing videos and i
had very few
young turks attacked me they started the
fight this was back on youtube when
there were no conservatives right there
were no conservatives it was all edgy
atheists and liberals and young turks
were sort of seen as i guess counter
culture somehow
um and uh they were actually going after
after me and they actually went after my
friend lee dorn who at the time he's a
lawyer who
had a small channel like 50 000
subscribers
so i remember thinking like oh one day
i'll show you
um and here we are but it's kind of like
um it's kind of like
when rocky marciano fought joe lewis
like how does it feel beating julius he
was like that was no joel lewis
that fighter i beat out there that's not
the joe lewis i grew up watching it's
like the young turks now it doesn't
really matter
i didn't know they were still really
around i know i know and with so much
money
so i was going to say i don't think joe
lewis had
heavy investment from al jazeera
a little bit more i think my biggest
issue is
i mean they're no good yeah yeah so you
have a hollow victory
you can do you can do better let me give
you yes exactly but this is
when we say independent news we mean
like actually independent we don't have
anything but you're a little late
you guys invented fireworks you should
know better what are you gonna do next
overcook your noodles
um yes the answer is yes so the young
turks they're they're uh that people are
saying congratulations to the five
million to me that doesn't really matter
what matters is passing the young tricks
and then i realize that doesn't really
matter
yeah um and i told you i made this
promise to you guys once we pass the
young turks and overall subscribership
that we will i will no longer be
using them as a source to rebut i will
no longer be making fun of them i will
at the end of this show retire once and
for all
um my chain compression and my costume
because i don't want to be a bully this
is kind of like right now it's like as a
kid you know you imagine
showing up to your yeah your bully and
going back and telling them what's what
and then he's got a potbelly and he's
bald and he's divorced and like
that's kind of what this is but i still
have to do it
i have to do this so because what
happened was they attacked me early on
and then what really bothered me you
understand i was a little
young kid when the union assault
happened in lansing michigan so i had
gigabytes of footage i'm giving you the
saga of steven crowd and the young turks
gigabytes of footage that i tried to
submit to the local uh the local uh d.a
or the local police
they said that i couldn't submit it
because i was no longer in lansing i
didn't live in lansing which of course i
found out later is untrue so none of my
evidence was submitted
but the young turks actually did a video
claiming that they had watched the
footage and i commit a crime
which the local district attorney used
as evidence so this is what the young
turks did
so in that edited video it appears that
the man is standing calm
in the beginning and then sucker punches
uh crowder out of nowhere
turns out when you look at the full tape
not exactly
how it went down oh my god i forgot how
different he looks now he has changed
the years have not been kind to him and
i see this as someone who is aging at an
accelerated rate like a paddling in the
soul chair
but this is what happened i was you know
i was assaulted by a union member uh and
we uploaded this footage and then sucker
punched yeah sucker punched sucker
punched
and then after uh when they did this and
the d.a said or i don't know if his
district attorney was prosecuting
attorney exactly said like well i
watched from the young turks commentary
and it was pretty clear
that uh stephen had pushed a gentleman
first it was a deposition i didn't know
what's happening and i wasn't even there
yeah um and my evidence had never been
submitted so i did upload
this so you can see for yourself
unedited two simultaneous angles
of this assault footage uh which youtube
then labeled age inappropriate so no one
could see it but here you go
see that right there they're cutting
that tent with box cutters that's what
you're seeing
right there see that guy's stabbing it
with a box cutter you can find that
footage
[Applause]
[Music]
over under clinch and then i just turtle
because there's 500. listen to this
[Music]
guy followed me to my car by the way i
remember that oh yeah no no no
police had no interest in the footage
and there's also in the unedited footage
there was
prior to that you could see that union
gentleman he told everyone it was betsy
devos's grandson
like he's pretty devoted it's like with
my fictional
my fictional grandmother employs you
right exactly so you guys were you guys
were in this tent that was being
attacked by people the only thing that
you guys went out to do was to say hey
guys stop stopping yeah there were women
there were kids in there with family
events stop doing this and
this is a response i still have a piece
of the tent it was cut out with box
cutters yeah
and i saw it coming like a cartoon just
like like the grinch cutting through the
paper going
a box cutter yeah and i remember this
was the first time in my life where i
really had this huge platform right the
young person i feel very
powerless because like well here i'm
going to upload the unedited footage i
couldn't submit it to the cops youtube
said it's age inappropriate so no one
could see it
and the young churches went out and lied
about it and it was actually you realize
it was actually admitted as evidence
just him talking about something right
exactly they didn't actually show
and this is so this went on for a while
and um obviously this is an independent
channel
and uh the crazy funding for the young
turks a lot of people don't know this
story
the 4 million in 2014 i think was from
buddy romer
uh they got another 4.25 in 2015 so
right now yeah we're 8.25 million
another 20 million in 2017 they received
300 million in google funds for training
journalists i don't really know
i don't really know what this was so
when i was small right really small uh
as a channel it's what the young church
would do they would go after me and then
started growing and calling them out
nothing
nothing i couldn't get them to show up
uh
i remember there was like politicon was
a small thing as well dude if it's [ __ ]
nothing
nothing this was very for a very long
time all of a sudden it was like a ghost
and it existed under their bed
um because you could punch back then yes
right you started when i was small
that's that's the thing is that's why
after we do this and we we give them
their eulogy that we'll never ever
address the young turks again it's the
end of an era it's the end
of a two-bit hack era um and the young
turks speaking of social media you know
people often wonder why i have such an
extra ground with big tech
the young turks they were actually
broadcasting youtube created a space
youtube space and the young turks had a
studio there yeah my brother used to go
in there and do freelance work and he'd
see jank all the time
they were just like poor babies no i
don't even know if they were buddies
but the guy that's where the bacon
grease joke came from
because he would bring his own jar of
bacon trees no
so this is what happened i kept wanting
a debate with chank wieger because he
had attacked me when i was young
not 20 years old and had no ability to
punch back and then he wouldn't respond
and so then what happened was and this
is something that obviously is pretty
shitty on my part but i don't apologize
i started doing sketches as
chank wieger as you guys will know this
has been going on for a while but here's
something that a lot of people don't
know
i did these sketches as chang wieger and
what i did was um i found out through
the grapevine that they really hated it
i think we'll have to do more yes of
course so then what i did was i actually
did
a sketch is chenk weaker with all of the
big youtubers at the times like alex
jones lauren southern benjaminopolis and
i gave them the video i said just upload
to your own channel
yeah so that when you search we here are
young turks this is what showed up
and then i also ran these sketches
as ads prior to young turks videos
cruel it's pre-rolled out so brilliant
they were speaking with an expert at
google who was like what's this
targeting pixel like you didn't worry
about that one
yeah uh and of course they were
rightfully furious because this was you
for a period in time a glorious period
in time when you were to click and watch
a young tricks video
you saw one of these sketches as an ad
before it
when you use the f word you know it's
real time okay i've heard about your
show and stuff so i want to no
ask you a question no i said get him off
the phone okay
[ __ ] off the phone you jewish shekel
collecting
whoa you say the water makes the frogs
gay man are you gay
look at you guys yes
yes
[Laughter]
keep in mind the context of that which
for people who might be
dave rubin worked for the young turks
left them which already kind of
grinded their gears then had a pretty
successful youtube channel
i produced a video as jane wieger with
dave rubin
let dave rubin upload it to his channel
and then i also ran these as
advertisements before young church
that's pretty that's when they truly
began to love you yes
uh and then i still though no response
we only would hear through the grapevine
that they didn't like it and then i was
i was no longer allowed to run them as
ads and i was like wow
skunked again and i really really wanted
to get my hands on shane
wieger the young turks and i couldn't so
this is probably one of the most cringe
i've talked about the most uncomfortable
i've ever been in my life yeah
and it was when i did this and i'll give
you the full story after this clip
but the only way that i thought i could
actually
physically be in the same room and
engage in some kind of debate with chank
wieger
was to crash a south by southwest
panel in austin with chank wieger um
as as chang wieger i apologize for the
cringe
still banned but do respect the
commitment to character this
actually happened alive
okay so steven crowder this is what he
does right and then uh
the security leaves they just leave him
there obviously i'm not doing i'm not
doing anything
right yeah i would never actually don't
just i don't personally dislike the guy
at this point
but i went to an empty chair and i have
to sit down and she's like
don't sit down because he knows
that i'm not going anywhere until i was
physically he's not gonna break
character
by security and here's the thing so that
was at south by southwest
there are two marriotts in austin there
yes one is across the bridge is it south
lamar is that where it is or
i don't know so whatever so i was there
for south by southwest
and i dressed up in a bathroom as chain
wieger right uh
ch chang chan jank however it's
pronounced um and uh i
who cares anymore i was dressed up i had
actual bacon grease because i had a jar
that we kept uh
cooking grease and actually use it
because i wanted to i wanted a daniel
day duelist right i wasn't gonna be lazy
yeah and i put it and i'm waiting in the
bathroom and i had heard that bill nye
was out in the hall for some reason
and uh i knew that i was going to i
think it was like ballroom b in the
marriott so i'm waiting in the bathroom
and then uh i get a text saying crap
crap crap he's at the other
marriott and they've already started
so i have to get in one of these what's
glorified like pedal cab you know it's
like when it's like golf pedicure parts
yeah but it's like a bubble yeah and i'm
i run in there covered in bacon crease
in a bubble like a jetsons car as they
drive me over
to the marriott oh my god and the
security at the front door didn't even
stop me
they went hey i said no no it's my panel
uh and i have never been so
uncomfortable in my
life i didn't want to do it but at a
certain point you have to
yeah i respect you for that one because
you've you've dressed up as a [ __ ]
several times and this is the most
uncomfortable you've been
yeah in in any way i haven't dressed up
i've dressed up as women so careful oh
well i've dressed up as well
disrespectful i have dressed up as
actual women right and you
copy pasted your little hate speech
there um and this you may not know the
bacon grease you know i actually had to
use bacon grease because
little known fact like chiang wieger uh
he he
everyone knows that okay he's a guy who
likes to eat right no he really likes to
eat
and as it turns out literally two
minutes
before we came on air i had not one
but two episodes which is amazing so
these are ideas about food epiphanies
about food
yes don't like spicy food as much as
i like non-spicy food but with spicy
food tortilla flour tortillas i didn't
like spicy food
corn tortilla i love ground beef i don't
like to eat corn tortillas but if you
fry anything enough i'll eat it
was terrible but obviously seems
delicious
oh my god i was like oh my god
like i joe biden myself like
like i leaned in the middle of the road
yeah no no
i leaned in and i was like oh jane
oh my god
if they just did this show anyway this
is getting uncomfortable
guy fieri already took up that spot
[Laughter]
i'll bleach my hair i could go to a dash
okay listen no one likes drive-ins and
diners more than me
and here's and then the only time that
in like i would say eight years
the young turks actually ever addressed
me publicly was of course a lie
and uh what it was was uh i i actually
found this
this is really and i know for some
people maybe this is inside but this is
just this
this kind of matters to me because it's
sad this is me saying goodbye to
something that helped shape who i am
it was the christine blasey ford saga
and it's an accomplishment it's
something that i hope is on my headstone
that i was called a garbage person
oh by anna kasparian um where they lied
and took a joke out of context and
immediately lost
tens of thousands of subscribers so
here's the lie so he called her a lying
[ __ ] and uh he also accused her
of uh calling someone a rapist with no
evidence uh she did not call anyone a
rapist
but nonetheless stephen crowder i mean
this is what you can expect from
trash like him i apologize i misquoted
trash yes not garbage
i don't want this whole video to be
fact-checked by youtube yeah
and the young teacher because i have a
job i misquoted an insult to myself
so no first off she's wrong about all
christine blasey ford did accuse i mean
yeah do we not remember that she accused
brett kavanaugh of rape no no she
gang rapist well that was that was the
other one oh that was sweaty
okay uh and to be clear this is one of
the this is a rule that i have for
anyone out there who's creating new
content and this is really what this
segment
why this segment matters people are
planning on creating new content you
know when i was coming up
it was the era of the young turks and uh
i didn't know if this would
exist as you guys watch it now uh i'm so
grateful because
we there was no are we there yet because
there was no there yet
every day is a new there yet uh but if
you
say anything or if you make a joke or
something that you think could be taken
out of context
just make sure you say it so that if
people extend that clip 30 seconds in
either direction
they go oh well now i know what he's
saying yeah that's a rule that i follow
and it's one that the young tricks i
guess have never heard of or or the
media because this is
uh no i didn't just say christine blasey
ford's lying [ __ ]
this was the joke that was taken out of
context
let me recap this for you four accused
kavanagh attempted rape and a letter to
diane feinstein that feinstein didn't
mention until after the hearings
feinstein said tuesday she can't vouch
for everything whether it's true or not
four doesn't remember exactly when it
happened or where
it happened her story contradicts the
therapist the attorney story contradicts
forwards an attorney that originally
said ford
would testify is now i think saying that
she's not going to testify was putting
retainer on august at which point she
took a lie detector test for an
accusation she claims
she was never going to make publicly at
all should be noted investigators
are saying that there is still the noted
possibility of ford being a dirty lying
[ __ ]
it's a good joke that was fun
possibility is still open
from investigators yeah not from me
right right it's a quote
yes about a possibility it's a quote
about a possibility
i would never say that no certainly it's
a joke show but this is the thing
is is they apply these standards right
with the young and i think this is why
they've lost so many viewers and it's
kind of sad even though what we've
tallied up 30 something 40 something
million thousand investment
unbelievable by the way i haven't taken
money for investment from
any kind of a foreign caliphate it's
mugs
it's you guys i know pbs says they're
funded by viewers like you
in whichever way mitt romney votes but
really wait so am i not supposed to be
taking money from
foreign beijing or am i supposed to talk
about it later i mean details you can
work out the details but
i will say uh the women they look mighty
fine
here's the thing we are funded entirely
by you
you join up club loudoscotto.com and
taken funding from qatar
from al jazeera which became current tv
or al gore
we've never had to so this is why this
is kind of a significant moment in
history
because often people claim hey we're the
top independent news channel
this actually is an independent news
channel we don't have allies uh
anywhere no no no of course the blaze we
work with obviously i mean
like nbc vox universal abc disney turner
comcast
we're not going to be setting up shop in
youtube studios anytime soon in marina
del rey i don't even know what's the
whole thing
but we were clearly not welcome and it's
okay
i wouldn't welcome me either but i think
they took it out of context because they
don't want
people to know even though they've
become social justice warriors today
their track record the young turks
specifically of misogyny and
the way that they treat women without
irony
now uh steve crowder is
[Music]
a gross person we have a cameltoe photo
for you
oh wow okay i mean that's my bias
against him but
and and you have to guess who the owner
of that camel toe is
you don't need to uh believe me you can
see for yourselves that makes me think
demi moore well she looks young
it's a signal to his misogynistic uh
viewers
never respect a woman i'm gonna go demi
moore no her breasts are not large
enough that's crazy
you [ __ ] out yeah or you [ __ ] other
women jake is like making a porn plot in
his mind
how are you doing tiger if you have a
short haircut they're like yeah yeah
lesbian put her in the lesbian stuff
always you know find a way to put women
down one way or another
if assuming she's a five rather than a
three
and right there there's no way i would
hook up with her later they can say oh
i'm not a [ __ ]
i just drunk what could i do pressed up
against the window uh-huh uh-huh
that's how you do it but nonetheless
stephen crowder i mean
this is what you can expect from trash
like him i love the
ultimatum there if you don't respect me
you don't treat me well i'm gonna [ __ ]
other women
that's gonna happen no but that's right
and guess what that'll work
i would love bestiality where you are
where you are pleasuring the animal
because we are going to denigrate what
and try to humiliate every woman
and my audience is going to get off on
that is what he thinks because megan fox
has like larger breasts than that and
you can't quite tell
can't tell yeah but she has nice rack
right go ahead and cry stephen cry
all day long and we know exactly what
you're about
and at least thank you for giving us
clarity on how you feel about
her and women in general come on i mean
what kind of a free country
are we if we can't even [ __ ] someone's
wife
my wife and i did not have sex until our
wedding night
it was definitely more fun yeah that was
fun more fun
i think it's objectification of women to
rank them by number
one horrible also what's most offensive
is how flippant
uh how flippantly he disregards to me
more like she has a small rack like
oh she'll be heartbroken yeah yeah
she'll be heartbroken you third string
turkish wrestler tons of fun doesn't
like me oh no
i forgot how bad that was yeah that was
pretty brutal
and i wouldn't have any problem with it
if there's like hey you know what i said
i would legalize bestiality
oh i was very shocked by that i yeah
i've never heard that
you were shocked see this is the thing
i've lived this is why i say i've lived
in this bubble
for years i've been here since 2006
right on youtube 2008 doing political
videos and you have to understand like
that was the everest to climb so for me
this is a surreal moment
it's just i kind of arrived here and
nothing's ever quite what you expected
it's like getting to the top of
kilimanjaro and there's you know there's
a dairy queen
and you're like they ruined it it's a
tourist trap
i thought this would be pristine and
untouched but you still got a blizzard
yeah i did get a blizzard i turned it
upside down i was like oh it really is
thick it's true
sick just like i like my women and so
now
that's the point though and i i will say
this listen thank you so much to
everyone who subscribed who has
supported this channel it's been a
really wild ride during
election cycle 2016 that's when we went
daily to election cycle recently
um and we don't really like to talk
about
about numbers because those things ebb
and flow really what means the most to
us
is you is you because we know that at
one point i was that misfit i'll tell
you this i was the misfit where
really i had no idea that it would ever
work
uh doing anything conservative on
youtube all i've been told my whole life
was well
fox news conservatives don't like this
kind of comedy yeah well i do
so maybe i'm an anomaly and same thing
on youtube well it didn't exist and the
algorithms kept favoring everything to
the left so i thought well you know what
maybe i just have to when we first
launched this show to give you an idea
we actually first launched the show as a
podcast uh it got
2 000 plays oh and we said i guess no
one's just gonna pay
because at this point everyone was
saying hey hey all the media consultants
would come and say do short form content
like
if your thing is 30 seconds edit it down
to
20 seconds and then if you could add in
a cat and like a piano
or a funny tie or a turtle humping a
timberland like that's what will work
long-form content won't work and so we
actually considered at one point
just making this show all of the content
exclusive
uh to mug club and earning a living but
like well you know what i guess it's
just an uphill battle where we'll never
be able to have the kind of influence
that the left would be able to have
because
there just isn't that ability so that's
an actual conversation that had taken
place
and it was a real heart to heart that i
had to have with uh even my wife going
hey
you know that stuff that i really wanted
to set out and accomplish i don't really
know if we
we can do it because there are people
and i remember saying
like i can't compete with over 30
million dollars in funding
if we're both independent i said i just
i just can't i'm just going to be
snuffed out so
i say this because anyone out there who
who thinks that the current landscape
is what it will be 10 years from now
don't lose heart it really can change
it's kind of like we talked about with
free enterprise and conservatives now
the left says i want my piece of the pie
we know as conservatives
you can bake more pies and i've said
that and people oh this is propaganda
from
capitalists who want you to keep feeding
into the system no no look look look
this right now what you are watching
this is a whole new pie
there was no peace of the conservative
of the right leaning of the independent
of the libertarian voice there was no
piece of that pie
on youtube or this was before facebook
was a thing
this is a whole new pie and now everyone
gets to benefit
from the whole new pie and so here we
are it's kind of bittersweet because
um you know the young turks their
numbers keep dwindling and going down
it's not really a worthy adversary where
now we kind of have to go after cnn and
bigger networks
um and uh i don't think that we'll ever
get to have any of those debates because
now i can't do it i would be a bully
um and uh i do appreciate you bringing
us here i guess
as one final time i should give you one
final one for the road
yeah thank you guys okay that's right
it's been a great ride
but uh this is [ __ ] and uh it is
time to officially
retire the young turks chunk wieger uh
costume and character
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you